[Musique]
c'était un jour pas comme les autres
pour les jeunes gymnastes réunionnais le
championnat de la réunion a eu lieu au
sein de nijim réunion habillés aux
couleurs de leur club
petits et grands vont venir
[Musique]
tu connais le réglage de trampoline au
doigt de pied près les enfants passent
de façon studieuse d'un agréé à l'autre
la rigueur de ce sport accompagner
financièrement par le département se
fait sous le regard expert des
entraîneurs et surtout des cadres
techniques âme à la démission
ministérielle la fédération c'est
d'avoir mis ou de mettre en place la
bière au dispositif pour la performance
et le haut niveau dans tout est décuplé
dans la vie et on est vraiment dans le
coeur du sujet puisque on a mis en place
depuis le 1er janvier
cette 2018 on est sur la création et la
mise en place effective du centre
régional ou du centre réunionnais
d'entraînement gymnastique
et dans la salle une bataille a eu lieu
pour la première place chez les
féminines à la barre parallèle la
championne de france en titre lille
aucune angoisse il est venu d'ailleurs
toutes ces mamans
je me dis qu'on a ici
le petit garçon
maîtriser ses émotions maîtriser son
corps maîtriser son espace
cette discipline est exigeante pour ses
enfants et si les traditionnels club de
champions comme le port saint denis ou
saint-benoît près par l'élite nationale
des 12 clubs constituent un vivier avec
deux fois plus de licenciés cette année
le club de saint pierre est en pleine
expansion
ce que je me considérais comme un peu ce
club et que
il est passé de 300 à 600 maisons pieds
tu aimes et ça
associés en qualité on a réussi à créer
un sport études
et merde face aux classes à horaires
allemand
par contre ça demande beaucoup
d'investissement des cards beaucoup de
passion
une jolie complète y compris vos mon
club
dans quelques semaines plusieurs enfants
participeront au championnat de france
une génération qui vise le lin pis mme
avec paris 2024 et ici c'est possible de
rêver
[Musique]